bishop c2 queen dc and he will check me
at on h7 but i feel like there might be
some okay to check yeah that's that's
kind of the critical
uh reaction getting counter play but of
course white will not
what queen c7 no i mean no way queen c7
how do you stop this queen dc bishop c2
you you just can't stop no queen dc is
winning the game
you just set up the battery and threaten
mate on eight seven but maybe oh you
don't have time for queen f4 queen f6
yeah you don't have time that's that's
the point yeah
i mean
teddy bear missed by yeah this this is
checkmate so
queen have four on the board what is he
missing or what are we missing after
bishop c2 no nothing yeah eric
yeah he completely missed yeah because i
mean of course the the position was
calling for for duke to check but the
question was what
i mean how to defend after bishop c2
because of course
we cannot take the rook because then we
need to check and suddenly after king hd
bishop d6 black is the one who threatens
all kinds of checkmates and and white's
king is in trouble it's a very sharp
position